nous sommes au coeur du portugal dans la
toute première capitale du pays
coimbra est construite sur une colline
alors un seul regard suffit pour la
découvrir
plusieurs centaines de marches pour
atteindre le sommet de la ville où se
trouve notre première incontournable
dans l'ancien palais royal se cache la
plus vieille université du pays
inaugurée au xiiie siècle elle accueille
chaque année près de 25 mille étudiants
qui célèbrent à leur façon
la fin des examens
c'est le costume traditionnel de coimbra
tous les étudiants en possèdent un
le sort pour les grandes occasions et il
a même inspiré la tenue de harry potter
mais ici pas de baguette magique
pourtant l'endroit regorge de même de
trésors en tout genre que nous fait
découvrir notre guide
christina
c'est la bibliothèque chine johan une à
cause du nom du roi il a fait construire
cette bibliothèque
en 1717 cette bibliothèque a presque
soixante mille livres est la plupart ces
60 mes livres ils sont datés du 16e au
18e siècle c'est donc l'une des plus
belles collections de livres au monde
qui d'ailleurs est toujours consultable
par les étudiants
après cette matinée est très studieuse
il est temps de se diriger vers notre
hôtel ou une belle surprise nous attend
une vue à 360° sur coimbra d'ici là
je vous emmène sur la terrasse ict'in
hester et voici la vue faubourg soliste
c'est splendide nom mais qui connaît une
fille si je vais l on peut voir la
bibliothèque jouanny n'invitait quechua
nine le quartier historique ça vous
permet de découvrir toute la beauté
à la tombée de la nuit coimbra change
d'ambiance les rues se vident c'est donc
l'heure pour nous d'aller dîner
le restaurant est en fait construit dans
l'ancienne fabrique de poterie de la
ville ici il est possible de dîner à
côté des anciens fours à porcelaine et
surtout de visiter les lieux micheline
s'y accumulent un regarder ce sont de
vieux moulin août montrent une centaine
toute la vaisselle du restaurant à
d'ailleurs été fabriqués ici au menu
uniquement des spécialités portugaises
comme la fameuse morue appelé ici
bacalao
aussi impressionnant que cela puisse
paraître à coimbra il est possible de
visiter tous les plus grands monuments
du portugal sans quitter la ville
le tout version miniature
ici comme but divers c'est à pas de
géant que l'on visite porto faro ou
encore lisbonne
et qui nous avons recréé un ensemble
monumental de lisbonne avec la tour de
belem le monastère des hiéronymites
maison des points c'est le tonneau l'arc
de triomphe de la rue de l'yser fayot
que nous voulions que les gens veuillent
5 g apprend-on il a fallu 20 ans
construit
notre tour est clair du portugal
terminée il nous reste encore une
dernière étape quasi obligatoire
lorsqu'on visite la ville
écoutez du fado dans les nombreux
restaurants ou cafés de la ville dans
l'un d'eux nous attend zhao l'un des
plus grands chanteurs du pays
alors est-ce qu'on se trouve nous sommes
à la maison du fado
à côté de la salle de concert se trouve
un atelier très particulier
alors ici c'est notre atelier de luthier
où nous fabriquons les instruments pour
le favori comme la mandoline ou encore
la guitare portugaise à huit cordes
l'atelier est réputé pour la qualité de
ses instruments
c'est un viol at au ra c'est le premier
instrument utilisé pour jouer du fado à
coimbra
[Musique]
et si la troisième ville du portugal
était le trésor caché du pays braga un
dédale de petites rues qui vous
emmèneront tout vers des lieux
impressionnant et pour cause la ville
est surnommée la rom portugaise au vu
des dizaines de monuments présent il n'y
a qu'à en choisir un pour commencer
votre week-end
construite à flanc de falaise l'église
de bom jesus est sûrement la plus
impressionnante de la ville nous y
retrouvons marianne a
alors mis à braga guides touristiques
comme j'ai juste c'est vraiment très
familial dans les gens viennent se
balader et du cou mais avant d'en
profiter il va falloir gravir quelques
600 marche alors un conseil
prévoyez de bonnes chaussures
la montée vaut tout de même le détour
elle offre une vue imprenable sur toute
la ville pense qu'une jeune âge manta
n'zi sien on peut même apercevoir la
plage quand le ciel est dégagé
elle n'est qu'à 30 km
et nous voilà enfin à l'église à
l'intérieur un style baroque est une
collection d'oeuvres d'art dont vous
pourrez profiter totalement gratuitement
après cette visite il nous faut
redescendre mais cette fois ci pas par
les escaliers
en route pour notre deuxième
incontournable un palais qui va nous
faire voyager dans le temps jardin à la
française façade monumentale c'est
simple ici rien n'a changé depuis le
xviiie siècle
bonjour bienvenue au palais à bischheim
noces en fait nous avons fait ce lieu un
musée pour montrer comment la
bourgeoisie portugaise d'yvette à libre
à peine le patio traversée chaque porte
nous emmène un peu plus dans le passé
salle de bal salons de réception et bien
sûr la salle à manger avec tous ces
ustensiles d'un autre temps
yougoslavie ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
entre brigue et uniquement cela
permettait aux convives de se laver les
mains entre chaque plat est dans la
cuisine tous les ancêtres de nos
appareils électroménagers ou granit
woippy si il y avait un foyer en granit
en bras de l'armoire qui permettait de
chauffer tous les plats c'est un peu le
micro-ondes du xviiie siècle de quoi
nous ouvrir l'appétit cela tombe bien à
braga les spécialités culinaires ne
manquent pas c'est notre bons plans du
week-end à l'échelle et apprendre à
faire de la soupe aux choux portugaise
christina est la spécialiste de cette
recette typique du nord du portugal qui
au vu de tous les ingrédients
nécessaires on va mettre 200 millilitres
d'huile vous remplira à coup sûr le
vendre on est beaucoup de villes en même
ajouter aussi des oignons de l'ail du
sou des pommes de terre du chorizo et un
peu d'huile de coude
nettoyez franchement
moi je le fais de manière traditionnelle
comme je l'aï appris de mes parents et
de mes grands parents après 30 minutes
de travail assidu nouveau goûté le
résultat lazier sailly
et est à ricky est très amoureuse c'est
donc re plus que nous nous dirigeons
vers notre hôtel qui n'est autre qu'un
ancien monastère
bonjour bienvenue dans notre hôtel
comme ça il faut dire qu'avec plus de
vingt-cinq églises dans son centre ville
braga a dû pour certaines leur trouver
une autre fonction c'est
l'idée a été de maintenir le style du
monument initiaux et qu'il faut être
très calme et silencieux à l'image des
moines bénédictins
antivivisection car vous devrez partager
le lieu avec des moines et des nonnes
voilà pourquoi vous ne trouverez ici ni
celle de ce corps ni piscine mais plutôt
une chapelle aux inquiets aux et voilà
le coeur de l'hôtel ce notre chapelle et
la rue le propriétaire de l'endroit
jésus j'ai vu comme tout le nord du
portugal braga est connu pour son vin la
ville est entourée par des vignes où est
produit le fameux porto voilà pourquoi
nous avons décidé d'aller dans une
brasserie
zhao produit sa bière artisanale et
n'allez pas croire que l'héritage
viticoles de la région a été totalement
mis de côté
et je fais remonter la bière dans un
tonneau de chaîne on utilise pour le
porter
ça donne plus de saveur a lâché
après un an de fermentation ne reste
plus qu'à goûter normalement on la sert
un peu fraîche à huy le mélange est un
peu étonnant c
avant de quitter la ville il nous reste
à découvrir une spécialité
rendez vous est pris dans la plus
vieille fabrique de coop du pays ici
tout est fait à la main du moulage
jusqu'à la peinture
tu m'as commencé par faire des points
bleus sur le corps plus facile à dire
qu'à faire mais après quelques
tentatives
mais c'est très bien tu devrais venir
travailler avec nous c'est le début
peut-être d'une nouvelle carrière
[Musique]
à moins d'une heure au sud de porto sur
les bords de l'atlantique émerge une
ville au charme très méditerranéen
aveyron ses façades colorées et ses
parterres de moselle où l'on se rend
rapidement compte que l'eau n'est jamais
bien loin
on les appelle les mots lycée roos car
il servait autrefois à récolter la
police un mélange d'algues utilisé comme
engrais mais aujourd'hui la seule chose
qui me transporte ce sont les touristes
nous montons à bord de l'une de ces
embarcations traditionnelles aveiro se
dévoile au fil de l'eau c'est vrai qu'il
ya un petit air de venise et puis visité
la ville sur l'eau c'est complètement
différente beaucoup plus tranquille
tranquille et sans effort au 19e siècle
il aurait fallu donner de sa personne
pour faire avancer le bateau
autrefois on utilisait selon badri ce
n'est pas une race il fallait le placer
au niveau de l'épaule et pousser au fond
de l'eau
suivre le fleuve c'est accepter de
quitter le centre-ville et se perdre
dans les marais salants toupance
la culture du sel a fait vivre la région
durant des siècles antonio est l'un des
derniers à le récolter toujours selon la
technique traditionnelle
il
est allé le cerveau bien de répartir à
la surface avant il y avait 152
mais aujourd'hui on est plus que
même si c'est un travail difficile c'est
un honneur de père j'étais sa négation
et moi je ne laisserai pas faire autre
chose et antonio n'est clairement pas le
seul à aimer les marais salants
[Musique]
ce spa à ciel ouvert est très prisé des
portugais
le sell side en expédiant naturel ça
permet d'avoir la fois douces
est-ce que c'est relaxant donc oui on se
la tranquillité la paix c'est trop bon
sous le soleil en plus du ressort
on a failli se laisser tenter mais nous
avions rendez vous avec mario pour la
visite de notre hébergement à quelques
mètres de là bienvenue dans la maison
bateau pour les galops prix de la nuit
120 euros pour dormir littéralement sur
la lagune
aucun briller c'est comme un bateau
et lorsqu'on rejoint la terrasse à
l'étagé c'est un peu le pont d'un navire
qui se dévoile avec ça on pourrait
vraiment navigué pendant une journée
nous quittons s'est étendue salée pour
une découverte cette fois très sucré
bienvenue à l'officine à dos et une
institution avions ici on cuisine des
hobos mollesse de mou depuis plus de 500
ans avant lennon se servait du blanc
d'oeuf pour repasser les vêtements ça
leur donner plus d'éclat
exactement c'est pour ça qu'on a eu
l'idée d'en faire des pâtisseries
il faut ensuite mélanger le jaune d'oeuf
avec de l'eau et du sucre pour obtenir
cette crème ne reste plus qu'à lui
donner une nouvelle coquille
- de bon
chacune de ces petites friandises
contient 70 calories autant qu'un yaourt
nature alors pourquoi s'en priver
le ventre bien rempli nous prenons la
direction d'une autre institution à
l'extérieur de la ville
et bienvenue à vitaly or les gardes nous
sommes au coeur de l'une des plus
grandes et des plus anciennes fabrique
de porcelaine du portugal
fondée en 1824 c'était à l'époque bien
plus qu'une simple usine
avec des habitations a même été fait
sens et les travailleurs puissent avoir
une vie sociale est aujourd'hui encore
le chat fait partie de l'identité
des bâtiments ont été en partie
reconvertie en musée il se visite pour 6
euros et certaines pièces valent le coup
d'oeil et vin chaud qu'à la regarder
celle ci par exemple c'est une assiette
qui a été offerte par le président du
portugal à la reine elizabeth la
porcelaine fait vraiment partie de notre
patrimoine au darfour d'ailleurs ainsi
que chaque famille portugaise à cette
gen 2
600 ouvriers travaillent toujours à
vista alegre comme isabelle elle peint
tout à la main et peut passer plusieurs
jours sur le même objet un mauvais coup
de pinceau et la pièce ne sortira jamais
de l'usiné où travaille toujours en
silence car c'est une tâche de haute
précision et je suis fier de faire
perdurer son savoir-faire
notre week end à aveiro ne pourrait être
complet sans un passage par son front de
mer
[Musique]
l'endroit est devenu célèbre grâce à ses
cabanes de pêcheurs rayé et bull qui
colore
on
[Musique]
raconte que les marins ont joint leurs
maisons quand ça pour pouvoir les
différencier lorsqu'il rentrait l'os
faire de la pêche un petit peu éméché
leurs rayures leur ont d'ailleurs valu
le surnom de maisons pyjama paulo notre
guide nous obtient une petite visite
improvisée regardez sa maman mais la
plus belle vue sur l'océan vous l'aurez
à 66 mètres du sol au sommet du plus
haut phare du portugal idéal pour
admirer un coucher de soleil sur
l'atlantique